the US government is on red alert this
time quite literally after the AP news
agency signed a memorandum of
understanding with Chinese counterparts
in who are the letter lawmakers sent to
the boss of Associated Press explains
that senior journalists are well
basically all spies and shouldn't be
dealt with at all Tsing hua serves some
of the functions of an intelligence
agency by gathering information and
producing classified reports for the
Chinese leadership on both domestic and
international events the congressmen and
women who signed the letter seem to be
bit out of the loop though because he's
a news flash AP and CIN who are have
been partners since 1972 this memorandum
is something of an official pinky
promise to stay friends and make each
other's jobs easier
the recent memo of understanding updates
a relationship that has been
consistently the same since 1972 and
opens the possibility for future
commercial interactions it does not
include or envision any sharing of
artificial intelligence information or
any other technology and normally this
indeed would be way under the radar of
the US government but this time the
Chinese are involved
Democrats and Republicans often seem
like they're ready to rip each other's
heads off but as soon as Beijing gets in
the picture oh they sing in tune
China's effort overtake the United
States as the world preeminent
superpower China is totally eating our
lunch they intend not just to supply in
America but all countries on earth and
the West Chinese ruthless in how they go
after us we're in a fight with China we
had to ride the China tiger
earlier this year The Wall Street
Journal reported that Washington was
mewling Brandin Singh who is a nasty
foreign agent this is what happened
without seeing the US this is what Al
Jazeera has so far been avoiding the
letter to the AP chief seems to continue
the trend when the American government
tries to sketch over the media landscape
the Mighty
we'll stand for now at least but the
foreign agent label begins to loom over
the horizon
you